okay guys don't be deceived for a
nanosecond by the democrats dramatic
warnings that the president that are not
fire special prosecutor mother better
not do it don't do it don't do they're
actually hoping he'll do just that
now that the credibility of the russia
probe is tarnished
after all the bombshell reporting we've
been doing on this show across a couple
of great news outlets the anti-trump
bias of the investigators is off the
charts firing muller
maybe the democrats only hope at this
point there's only one problem for them
the president isn't falling for it he
outsmarts them every time joining us now
to analyze ken starr was the independent
counsel in the Whitewater investigation
he's joining us from new york and in
sunny florida alan dershowitz harvard
law professor emeritus author of the
book trumped up alan you go from
Martha's Vineyard to Miami Beach to I
mean any any anything else I mean my
goodness it's great to see both of you
happy holidays Merry Christmas let's
start with you judge Starr you just
wrote a piece about the things that
you're concerned about in this
investigation you still respect Muller
and Rosenstein but you have you have
some issues but I want to start on this
this dramatic dire series of warnings
we're hearing from the Democrats about
firing Muller the president said he's
not going to fire Muller they've said it
multiple times but the drumbeat
continues what do you think it's about I
don't know what it's about but it's just
it's it's a call to sack because the
president I don't think is going to fire
Bob Mahler he's being advised to some
folks very wrongheaded layer saying you
need to fire Bob Muller
bad advice it's the wrong thing to do
but I don't think the president is going
to fall for it and with the fact we hear
from the White House and we hear from
the White House's lawyers from the
president's lawyers not going to do it
it would just be terrible we don't need
another Saturday night massacre should
Bob Muller have been appointed in the
first instance it's a fair question
back in May I was saying let's do not
have a special counsel I think we and I
agree with Alan on this we overly
lies so much of life in our politics
together we need to stop that and so I'm
also very concerned about the calls for
the appointment of yet another special
counsel I think it's all wrong yeah
let's go to Alan Dershowitz Alan
on this issue of the the Muller firing
and you get the sense that the Democrats
are just kind of running out of steam
that I think there's nothing happening
at least not yet on the Muller
investigation that we know of at least
so it's almost like they have to keep
the fumes going and this is all they
have I mean all day on the other
networks that's all they're talking
about right look my liberal colleagues
on the Left have been proved empirically
wrong in everything they've said they
said the Supreme Court would strike down
the travel ban it looks like they're
going to uphold it
they said the emoluments clause has been
violated today a federal judge said
that's a nonsensical argument they were
wrong about Flynn they're wrong about
firing Muller
they've just been wrong and it's not
because I'm smarter than they are that
I've been right and they've been wrong
it's they put hope over reality and I'm
just an analyst I'm just calling it as I
see it and it's easy to be right if
you're objective and call it the way it
is I think what's happening is both
sides of playing the refs but I think
the Trump side is playing them smarter
what they're doing is keeping the
pressure on Muller they're questioning
his integrity they're challenging
whether he had conflicts of interest
they're questioning whether he should
have gotten a warrant and they're hoping
that since they're putting pressure on
him and he has such concern about his
reputation that he may lean over
backwards in a closed case to support
the Trump side and the other side of
playing the refs they're just saying if
we push hard enough and say he's gonna
fire him he's gonna fire him he's gonna
fire him maybe we'll go to MIT to firing
him but right now the Trump side is
coming off better cuz I think they have
mullah where they want him and the last
thing Trump should do and I think would
do is fire Muller at this point no no no
the firing Comey wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't the best choice obviously the
last thing you want is that judge a
judge I want to you yeah I want to go to
you on the uranium one reopen of the
investigate
and that Jeff sessions has announced and
looks like they're gonna look at that
all anew you are concerned about this
because of the number of connections
from that deal to the Clinton Foundation
specifically tell us what the big red
flags are well the big red flags are
this multi-year process by which now the
transaction was completed years ago was
accompanied by enormous gifts to the
Clinton Foundation 31 million dollars
was the first gift after the first part
of the deal was signed in Kazakhstan
back in 2005 and then gifts kept coming
in from these senior officials from this
company again it went through
reorganization and so forth acquisition
and so I'm very deeply concerned about
the time including President Clinton's
speech for half a million dollars in
Russia the Russia connection I think all
these things I've always been in favor
of transparency I want to know the facts
I think we need to be cautious about
criminalizing everything that moves but
in terms of our politics we need to get
the facts out Alan I agree I agree
completely I completely agree I think we
need transparency that's why I call for
a nonpartisan independent investigatory
Commission like 9/11 which wasn't
pointing fingers at people criminally
buts goal was to try to find that
everything about Russia's involvement in
elections Russia's involvement and
economy and then make recommendations
for how to stop Russia from trying to
influence our democracy I think the
worst way to do it is through a special
counsel behind closed doors of the grand
jury all you get in the end probably is
either indictment or not indictment of
some low hanging fruit Alan do you think
it's interesting at the very least that
you had call me Rosenstein you had
McCabe and Muller
they were all involved in one way or
another in that Rosa Thom investigation
when they first approved the deal and
they looked into the investigate they
were all part of it it's just there's
like five people who seem to do
everything it's got the at the
Department but remember they come from
totally different backgrounds there's no
way they have any political interests in
common Muller is a Republican Rosenstein
we don't even know what his politics was
he was appointed by Obama having been
appointed previously the idea of Clinton
getting a half a million dollars George
Bush the first I think got fees like
that when he spoke in Japan former
presidents get big big big fees when
they speak again I don't want to point
the finger of criminalization on anybody
but I want to see like Ken wants to see
transparency let all the facts be late
for the American democracy when a
Russian interest through a Canadian
purchase is able to get control of 20%
of our uranium interests went through
this interagency process and all this
money's floating to the Clinton
Foundation at the same time for people
with interests in the transaction or
connection to the transaction I mean you
can ask a person on the street and they
would say that was a bad idea
I mean someone who has nothing to do
with the law or nothing to do with the
Committee on foreign investment they
would say gosh that seems really stupid
in my view yeah close it out my yeah my
focus is on the fact that there were
these enormous gifts enormous gifts to
the Clinton Foundation it's not whether
there was a proper interagency process
the nine agencies that are proved it and
so forth it may have been exactly the
right thing to do but why were these
gifts enormous in size given year after
year after year to the Clinton
Foundation I don't think that was a good
thing to do to have a Russian interest
everyone's always afraid of Russia now
Russia owns 20% of uranium stake and we
all think oh that could have been a good
thing I don't understand how you think
that could be a good I think I think
it's very clear that countries like
Kazakhstan and others I honestly believe
that you need to give gifts to get
things done they doesn't mean the
Clinton Foundation today if you want
Clinton Foundation's wonderful work
abroad for AIDS and everything else they
spend every penny on doing good so what
you're looking at is the intention of
the Kazakh authorities that's very
different than pointing the finger at
the Clintons all right both of you have
a wonderful holiday